in 2016 after then House Speaker Paul
Ryan endorsed Donald Trump for president
George will the most decorated
conservative newspaper columnist in
America officially left the Republican
Party he's been a thorn in Trump's side
ever since he doesn't understand the
vocabulary of American government he
doesn't understand the conversations
that are going on around him it's like a
twelve-year-old in a room with people
who specialized in quantum mechanics he
just is lost at all times but even while
bemoaning what he calls our
authoritarian moment will has not
abandoned conservatism to the contrary
in his career punctuating new book the
conservative sensibility will makes the
forceful argument that classical
liberalism based on natural rights and
the political philosophy of James
Madison is the correct path forward not
just for the GOP but for a country that
for too long has tilted toward Woodrow
Wilson's progressive super presidential
vision of government we caught up with
will the week his book came out so
George will thank you for joining us and
congratulations on a terrific and I
think consequential book thank you in
our year 2019 so you've been I think
you've been writing this thing for a
long time now I seem to recall nearly 10
years ago you're referring to this you
might've made a mordant joke about it
being a eulogy anywhere situate this if
you can within the context of your own
career no app century in Washington
writing about this stuff but also why in
2019 we need to be talking about the
kind of you know of the pitched battle
between James Madison and Woodrow Wilson
well those two Princetonian czar the
polar opposites in a way of our
political argument Madison said first we
believe in natural rights which is to
say first come rights then comes
government government is instituted and
the most important word in the
Declaration to secure our rights not to
give us our rights but to protect them
and inheriting inheritable link lumen of
government in the very definition of it
this was fine until Woodrow Wilson came
along and became the first president to
criticize the American Founding which he
didn't do periphery
he did root and branch he said the
medicines constitutional architecture
with its Newtonian equilibrium between
the branches interested in us combating
interest in this was fine he said when
there were four million of us and 80
percent of us lived within 20 miles of
Atlantic Tidewater but now he said we
are a great nation united by steel rails
and copper wires and most important we
have reached a point of enlightenment
that we don't need to worry about
factions anymore because as a broad
consensus furthermore Wilson came along
when science was in the air Marconi Ford
Edison of the Wright brothers and the
idea of applying science to society as
well as to the hard sciences cut their
imagination furthermore to get an
advanced degree in the United States in
the second half of the nineteenth
century you had to go to Germany to get
it and there were lots of people did and
they fell in love with the German state
the big alien idea of a disinterested
bureaucracy would be a long time before
public choice Theory came along and said
ah it's not as interested
it's a faction itself government is its
own faction and interest group but all
this came together and when when Woodrow
Wilson said we'd meet an or need a more
nimble government he used that phrase
when the can act with dispatch and force
of a sort that is simply impossible
under medicines architecture it flowed
from that that we had if presidents or
government that Congress should be
Marburg marginalized we didn't realize
how energetically it would marginalize
itself reversing Madison's prediction
that in a democratic society all power
is sucked into the legislative vortex
actually the legislature expels powers
so it can get on with the to business of
life which is to a avoid responsibility
by allowing the essentially legislating
to be
done by administrative agencies and be
to get reelected so that's where we are
we have a rampant presidency we have a
hollowed out supine boneless Congress
and no one's happy it strikes me in
reading some of the excesses of the
Progressive Era right Teddy Roosevelt
you also sort of single out early on and
and we have no trouble in figuring out
oh you know what prohibition of alcohol
was a disasters a terrible idea
or the eugenics that a lot of
progressives embrace including both
Roosevelt and Wilson in their own ways
that was just a terrible aberration and
some other things but the overall
critique of the kind of scientism the
bureaucracy didn't stick in a similar
way it's as if you could just jettison
the nasty parts without a thoroughgoing
was there a failure of identifying this
or have we just sort of forgotten that
there were critiques of that at the time
and they just lost the argument
we forgot historical amnesia is de
Tocqueville said a systemic problem of
democracies for we're looking at all
times
and we have forgotten it and we've as
you say we're going to keep the good
parts of progressivism but the good
parts of progressivism they're a family
resemblance to the bad parts which is
kind of overbearing us in Hayek's terms
a misapplication of the confidence and
the hubris if you will of the hard
sciences when applied to the
complexities of a society of spontaneous
order in his wonderful Nobel lecture
Hayek makes this point and he makes the
call for epistemic humility epistemology
being the branch of philosophy that
tells us how we know things and he says
most of us can know very little about
what's around us every day we get more
ignorant relative to what there is to
know but markets which are nothing but
mechanisms for generating and
aggregating information make us smarter
if we will listen to them the problem is
there's been a constant desire not to
listen to market
for lots of reasons you mention Hayek
here the book is filled with people who
I would describe as libertarian heroes
Milton Friedman's Virginia postural
there's Deirdre McCloskey there's Ilya
somin there's Randy Barnett there's the
Institute for justice I'm it's dedicated
to Barry Goldwater and the book is
called the conservative Sensibility why
is it called a conservative sensibility
because conservatism rightly understood
in America is the legacy of classic
liberalism liberals long since turned on
their own tradition of limited
government resistance to Authority and
conservatives took that over Barry
Goldwater I guess my first presidential
vote for Barry Goldwater he lost 44
states but I've always said he actually
won it just took 16 years to count the
votes Reagan came in but Barry Goldwater
came from a new part of America in the
southwest there's no there was nothing
out there when he was born when he built
his house on a little hill where as a
young man he used to ride his horse and
sleep under the sky there were a hundred
thousand people in the valley of the Sun
then to know them about four million
it's a place without a past so he gave
us a kind of libertarian mounted
leave-me-alone kind of western
conservatism which is in direct conflict
in 2019 with the European import it's
one of the grim paradoxes of our current
moment the people who say their purpose
is to make America great again want to
do that by importing European
conservatism blood soil thrown an altar
ethnicity language all that stuff that
gives a particular identity which they
want to preserve European conservatism
was about defending hierarchies and
established institutions in order
American conservatism is reconciling
people to a constant churning to the
radical openness of a society of
spontaneous order
is great you know dynamism in Virginia
pastels termini think use it and a lot
another buddy she said the most
wonderful thing I think it's it's in the
book I know it is
she said the Bible reduced to one
sentence is God created man and woman
and lost control of things now the
conservative sensibility says good
we don't want control that's the whole
point the anti conservative Sensibility
says oh it's dangerous it's tiring it's
worrisome and it's this anti
conservative hostility to the current
constant churning of a free society that
I am afraid is about to produce what
I'll call the big flinch people saying
freedom was alright once it's just too
stressful it's worrying and it and along
comes Walmart and destroys our lovely
little hardware store all of this that's
what protectionism is today is an
attempt to say enough we've had it we're
gonna hunker down the problem is the
American people whether they know it or
not and they don't have already made a
choice when they decided to have an
entitlement state Medicare Medicaid and
all the rest they decided that were
they're gonna make these enormous
promises to themselves enormous calls on
the future productivity of the country
they better attend to the future
productivity so they are wedded to
economic dynamism whether they know it
or not as you sort of referenced the
kind of upper hand right now since we
have an overly presidential system
whatever the president is is kind of the
definition the modern definition of what
conservatism ism or progressivism or
however you might put it is and right
now classical liberalism is dirty word
means in the last 10 days in in the
conservative commentariat of people just
scratching each other's eyeballs out
over the difference between a kind of
catholic integral integral ism and
classical liberalism i haven't seen the
word that term used as much in the past
ten days and i have since the last time
libertarian
tried to not describe themselves as
libertarians and using classical
liberalism itself so are you in in a
sense trying to make the Reagan argument
in 1976 he said to Reason magazine of
all places that the heart and soul of
conservatism is libertarianism are you
are you trying to say that yes you're
about to lose this concept and if you
don't watch out you're gonna drive out
those people from what should have been
in is a noble tradition classical
liberalism was born and resistance to
established churches entrenched
hierarchies all of that and it is it
defines itself in reaction against
potentially and often actually
oppressive institutions so there is that
Liberty Jean if you will it's in the
genome of American conservatism and yet
it's it's on the run as as we speak and
and being rapidly forgot I mean here's a
critique from the people who are railing
against classical liberalism in some
sense rail against you in particular is
that we're in a fight this is a flight
93 election yeah I feel like that
metaphor I despise it well let's have an
interjection of why do you despise that
metaphor I did too but I'm curious
Teri's because we bandy promiscuously
the idea of a crisis we're not in a
crisis now things are messy now I get
that but we've had one constitutional
crisis in this country and it was April
1861 when the institutions could not
handle the forces loose and we had four
years of saturation of blood and we got
over it Watergate wasn't a crisis
Watergate was misbehavior and we tidied
it up what is the crisis on these people
that we have a a conservative majority
on the Supreme Court and it's a rather
young about to be there what is the
crisis I just don't get the hysteria
built into the language well I mean part
of what your book does talk about is
kind of lead
integration of the family yes there are
indices that are unhappy right now and
also that our resistance to easy kind of
solutions or prescriptions of how we of
how we get there is is there something
in the because I I show the same thing
you know it's not a crisis look at the
last thirty years have been the most
unprecedented ly prosperous time in
American or in the world history in ways
that language is not even we don't have
enough language to talk about how
wonderful that is but is there something
in that triumphalism that has missed a
hole at the center of the enterprise and
that hole is something that you see
nationalists not just in this country
but around the world are eager to fill
up well they're two very different
things one is some people have been
casualties of the very process that has
enriched the majority and the casualties
are resentful which is understandable
and they should be helped as much as
possible granted on the other hand
there's another critique of classic
liberalism that is profoundly dangerous
and it is that it doesn't give me
meaning and life
it's a politics doesn't intoxicate me it
doesn't fill me with a sense of worth
and identity and mission good we've had
quite enough of political movements that
we're going to deliver all of those
things new Soviet man new Aryan man does
that any other thing politics shouldn't
be that important part of what is
interesting in the middle section of
your book is that you talk a least a
little bit about your statecraft a
soulcraft book from 30 years ago or so
and refute part of it you say I got
something wrong and and I think part of
and correct me my characterization air
but that you underestimated the way in
which the architecture of the
Constitution was in itself of soulcraft
that it created a sort of a template for
the creation kind of a virtuous society
or society that could become
self-governing and that you
underestimated that talk about that but
also maybe in the context of this which
is
your argument you're making a very
robust Madisonian arguments and against
progressives a progressive claim is that
this is old-fashioned stuff it's out of
date isn't on some level the fact that
you need to make this argument in fact
you need to make this argument to
Republicans may be a sign that the
progressive critique might be onto
something like it's the architecture
didn't work like some of the planks have
been pulled out of the ship and it's
it's just not making as much sense
anymore
my book is among other things that call
a summons to intelligent pessimism not
fatalism nothing's inevitable
but problems are probable there's so
many ways things can go wrong a free
society a democratic society is not the
default option of the human race it
takes construction it's a famous paradox
that laissez-faire is a government
program
it needs courts and needs contracts it
needs protection against fraud
adjudication arbitration all the rest
complex network to produce freedom I got
that but on the off chance that some of
your viewers have not recently reread
state craft or so craft which is read by
dozens that's when I came out let me
refer some 1981 I give them Godkin
lectures at Harvard and they became a
book called state craft as Soulcraft and
the subtitle is important what
government does not what government
should do but but it cannot help but do
and my thesis was that by its structure
of laws by the economic system it
chooses to create by lots of things it
changes sets out to change the soul of
America the soul of the citizens the
argument between the anti-federalists
and the Federalists wasn't it was
ostensibly about government it was about
government it was about what kind of
people were gonna be what kind of
Americans and we're going to be
Jefferson really wanted a sort of stable
self-perpetuating rural yeoman Murray
forever that would produce people rather
like Thomas Jefferson Hammond said none
on your life
I want Restless
entrepreneurial upwardly mobile
constantly churning people rather like
Alexander Hamilton well fair enough
little special pleading to hurt but they
were arguing about the kind of people we
were and and what I got wrong in
statecraft of Soulcraft as I did not
realize the extent to which the system
we had in terms of government which
shaped the kind of people we are and
most important what I missed was the
extent to which capitalism itself is
Soulcraft it's a wonderful passage and
de Tocqueville is democracy in America
he's travelling down in the 1830s the
Ohio River on his left his slave holding
Kentucky torpid no energy no progress no
sound of enterprise on his right is Ohio
fast lane cracked lane with energy
people producing getting wealthy and all
the rest thing there you had it a
certain kind of capitalism doesn't just
make us better off it makes us better it
enforces certain virtues thrift
industriousness deferral of
gratification individual aspiration on
flourishing that's Soulcraft you have a
pretty withering chapter in there about
foreign policy the series of monsters
that we've gone insurgent destroying and
also i think in a pretty interesting way
kind of talking about the i sort of an
attempted application of the same
natural rights philosophy that you were
defending in the book to the world we're
going we're going to since since iraq
people have the same aspirations and
natural rights we do we're going to make
that happen at that point of a gun what
do people get wrong in applying this
thing here there's a inherent tension
and american foreign policy that will
never be and should never be gone in my
judgment
we are a Creole nation we're a nation
dedicated to a proposition as Lincoln
said dedicating the cemetery
we are a nation made as Margaret
Thatcher said by philosophy
unlike European nations as she said are
made by history and our philosophy is
that to all Minds unclouded by
superstition that's what self-evident
means the self-evident truths are that
individuals are rights bearing and
governments should facilitate the
exercise of their rights and get out of
the way now the question is is everybody
ready at all times for this answer's no
George Bush a borrowing a line from
Ronald Reagan said it is cultural
condescension to say that the Iraqis are
not ready for democracy
it was condescending and it was true
that's more to the point I made this
analogy in the book go to spring
training a manager will say my team is
just two players away from the World
Series
unfortunately there Ruth and Gehrig Iraq
was just about three or four people away
from perfection from being ready today
and they needed a Washington a
charismatic founder of a republic he
needed a Madison a genius of
constitutional architecture to enable
factions with which Iraq was replete to
live together needed a John Marshall
someone who could construe a
constitution Abele over the years and
apply it to shifting circumstances you
needed an Alexander Hamilton who
understood the political economy of a
nation and you needed the social soil of
the Atlantic coast of the United States
and us in the 18th century from which
people like that emerged in something
like profusion so the tension in our
policy is we're on the side of the
world's embrace of our Creed because we
think it is self-evidently true
but not tomorrow not everywhere now and
that requires prudence that's what I
mean prudence is the fundamental
political virtue because it means
applying principles to messy
circumstances that's the one one person
who in modern politics who I would say
on some level agrees with the foreign
policy like litany of mistakes that you
spell out there Vietnam Iraq other kind
of nation building exercises and you
might bristle at this is Donald Trump
comparatively speaking compared to a lot
of politicians out there he ran against
Iraq and said this is a bad idea yeah I
just saw him I think this morning in
England or last night talking about his
own avoidance of Vietnam saying I am I
never I was never a fan of that war
which is a super crude thing for an
American president to say also a correct
judgment at least in my points of view
um is there an argument that Trump is a
use that use the metaphor of love like a
breaking up the crust around a cake a
few times in the book is Trump could he
be that in in that forcing conversations
about foreign policy for example that
wouldn't otherwise exist you to add an
another completely different topic of
that you talk about judicial restraint
and judicial engagement there and
Chevron deference deference which is
something that Neal Gorsuch a Donald
Trump appointee is the leading proponent
of breaking apart can Trump be this sort
of cake on crusting figure a bull in a
china shop getting us towards places
that we've needed to go and frankly that
the that the elite has in by staying
within the 35-yard lines have failed to
get us towards well I could say he's the
stopped clock that's right twice a day
but I would say several things of course
it's in the courts Trump probably got
elected because Scalia died
that is he made the court central and
won in court in two exit polls one in
five voters said they voted because of
the court and most of those were
conservatives but he got elected because
he says I promise not to exercise my
judgement about judges I'm gonna
outsource that to the federal society as
a result he came up with judges that any
Republican president would have come up
with same source from the Federalist
Society and of which I'm a member and
other groups I think the reaction
against Iraq and before that Vietnam was
mature before donor club Trump came
along and discovered that it was a good
vehicle mm-hmm so I think we I think
history hard cruel bloody history taught
us long before mr. Trump appeared now I
see critiques of you and your book in
this moment of discussion from the Left
congealing as a lot of discussion does
from the left these days around the
issue of race or immigration or some
kind of tribalism which is to say okay
mr. conservative have you not noticed
that this has been in the Republican
playbook forever preceding Donald Trump
Mitt Romney played from an
anti-immigration playbook for sure sound
lost and then lost one of the uglier
ideas and modern American politics was
Romney's self-deportation will make
people who were here illegally so
miserable I want to leave unworthy
aspiration is there something about the
I mean this goes back to Goldwater he
might have had perfectly principled
ideas to oppose the Civil Rights Act and
and I think did as expressed the
coalition around him might not have
shared his kind of highfalutin ideas
about political philosophy and we're
looking for an excuse to engage in
racism is there something or how would
you respond to the critique of that a
lot of modern conservatism including to
some degree of fealty towards classical
liberalism and a throwback to the
founders
is looking the other way while a
powerful class marginalizes those who
are not as powerful I think the
criticism was apt of a lot of people but
not of conservatism okay they should go
back and read Ronald Reagan's farewell
address our nation needs walls but the
walls should have gates and scepters
that the door should be wide open to
those who want to come in and be
Americans we merit a stood much the same
thing so there's that continuity on the
Taft Goldwater Reagan strand of the
Republican Party unlike the Teddy
Roosevelt Thomas Dewey rockefeller wing
of the party this is a simmering like a
sine wave it keeps coming and going
argument in the Republican Party most
conservatives are equipped with the
vocabulary to admire immigration because
to immigrate is an inherently
entrepreneurial act it is to uproot
yourself take a risk take the only
capital you've got which is your
enterprise and come to a foreign society
where you'll be linguistically
challenged and culturally disoriented
and prosper which they do furthermore
it's another thing about which Americans
have no choice sorry the puppy the
workforce is aging baby boomers are
retiring we very soon left 2.4 workers
for every retiree on Social Security
we must replenish the workforce and only
immigrants can do it as our fertility
rate continues to decline do you see
this future and you write a lot about
this the kind of entitlement math it
just it can't possibly add up so my
parents and relatives are all from from
Portland Oregon so I remember watching
Mount st. Helens blow up second or third
time in July of 1980 it's pretty great
but volcanoes go like this they go like
this Irvin says hey look it's growing
that's interesting
I grows and grows and then it blows up
and then
Harry Truman dies on the Tualatin river
but like it can be a big boom in a
catastrophic event or he could be Japan
the last 20-30 years you lose one decade
it's a slow leakage of power and
influence maybe you could say that the
modern UK is in a similar way how do you
look at this thing I don't see an
explosion a collapse nations really
don't go bankrupt
I do see a sort of drift into account of
entropy a kind of slowing of the
American pulse as we make all kinds of
adjustments to avoid all kinds of hard
choices we are going to have to means
test entitlement programs sooner or
later we're going we have attached and
the American people as a matter of
entitlement to our most dynamic science
which is medicine I give you all
interesting figures in 1900 if we'd had
national statistics which we didn't
because Simon Kuznets had not lived
medicine which is now 18% of our GDP
would have been too small to be included
in them in 1900 the American people
spent twice as much money on funerals as
they did on Medicine in 1937 percent of
all deaths were from infectious diseases
today it's 2% in 1900 only 17% of deaths
were over 65 people over 65 today it's
75 percent that's an enormous social
achievement it also is hugely expensive
longevity is a budgeters nightmare
because you live long enough you get to
become eligible for the most interesting
cocktail of diseases I forgot something
that 40% of American Medicare patients
are living with two or more chronic
ailments any one of which would have
killed them before the onset of modern
pharmacology another great blessing but
one expensive one so the American people
have made another choice they have
they've decided to live long and to be
supported in this by a government
they're gonna have to figure out ways to
pay for it
there you mentioned Richard Nixon
earlier or the kind of crisis of
Watergate that was was dealt with a lot
of people don't know the intellectual
history at least a little tiny wing of
it in which you played a role which is
you were a young National Review
reporter at the time or Washington
correspondent at the time 1971 there
were 72 73 writing things that were not
making the readers of National Review
necessarily very happy in your critique
of Richard Nixon at the time I want you
to make the comparison not of Trump to
Nixon of which that is an interesting
comparison but let's show that because I
think what's kind of interesting here is
how Republican public opinion or
conservative public opinion was with the
president like strongly for a really
long time until the moment that it
wasn't and there's a lot of habits of
mind that go with that sense of
tribalism or team membership or just
sort of support looking back on that
time do you see things that strike you
as what's happening now or actually
there are a lot of conservatives who
weren't really with Nixon heart and soul
until it became clear he was a crook oh
I'll tell you what in 1973 I leave the
Senate staff in January and become a
Washington bill Buckley's first
Washington editor National Review and
simultaneously began submitting columns
to the post which was planning to start
a syndication and they were gonna
syndicate me and David Broder so they
said here's how we can sell will we'll
say two editorial page editors across
the country at last someone dual support
Richard Nixon yeah you think it's funny
so by March Oh 73 yep I'm into this
business three months and it's quite
clear to me that where there's smoke
there's a lot of smoke and was it a lot
of smoke there's going to be a fire and
it was clear to me that Nixon was guilty
of at a minimum failure to superintend
the excesses of his subordinates which
is an impeachable offense in my judgment
so 40 some years later I'm right back
where I started
having difficulties for the Republican
president but then in those moments you
get the strange new respect from the
liberal media right I can do without
that frankly the bill the National
Review at that time as I recall this my
memory may be faulty would do an
analysis of their mail and they don't
memo on it there was a category
subscription cancellations in George
will they were the same thing there's a
lot and Bill Buckley to his great credit
National Review then as now but then
even more than now depended on the
largesse of true believers many of whom
supported Nixon and as I say many of
them didn't really warm to him until he
became embattled by people that these
people and these Nixon supporters
disliked more than they really liked
Nixon which in fact happened in a sense
under Bill Clinton as well I mean the
impeachment process brought out
progressives self-identified
progressives really for the first time
in 1998 they were they didn't like the
way that he triangulated he was a third
way guy he was a sister souljah moment
person but it was only then because we
saw all the troglodyte conservatives
come after him that we will exactly have
come in what do you do with that
knowledge that this is how people
respond to politics and and I may be a
append to that of did you see that the
the rise in the election of Trump but
just that the trumpian moment as a bit
of a wake-up call for how people in our
business do our work and analyze things
and synthesize things yes
increasingly partly because of what are
called social media and should we call
anti social media we live increasingly
an intellectual silos and we're
increasingly subject to confirmation
bias learning exactly what we want to
learn from sources we pick because we
only want to learn from them and it's
it's dumbing down the
public conversation there's no question
and so what do you do with that
information or it's knowing how people
respond to things I'm including knowing
how people responded to Richard Nixon
rallying around the person because he's
embattled more than adhering to an idea
does does this just mean that people of
principle are doomed to be a Justin
Amash floating around as a despised
character oh no Snyder it means there
always are in society a large number of
people who if they didn't have
situational ethics they'd have no ethics
at all and that's what they are and get
over it not that many people interested
in philosophic argument a large number
of Americans are but a larger number of
Americans art so you have to nourish
those who nice the conversation about
first principles and my book is in part
a summons to intelligent pessimism but
not fatalism and it it there's so many
things that can go wrong but the grounds
for optimism is that the political
philosophy that I call the conservative
sensibility has an enormous long and
distinguished pedigree going back just
in this country to after Locke to
Madison and Jefferson and Hamilton and
most of all Lincoln and that just
doesn't go away
because someone got more than 270
electoral votes just doesn't work that
way in fact you see people in the throws
of any hyper partisan moment which for
now it's it's permanent with us whoever
is basically losing an argument goes to
the founders right they and throw or if
they're losing an argument or waging an
argument gainst the president the
conservative incite and two words is
nothing less nothing you try and make
things last as long as possible but you
also the the the that's consoling also
in times like these hyper partisanship
well
last forever just won't people were
getting exhausted they'll get burnt over
and there will be better days before we
let you walk to your next 37 interviews
talking about this book you and I
Nicholas we talked I believe in 2016
early 2016 I in which you observe that
we're kind of living not through a
libertarian moment but an authoritarian
moments the way that you put it and we
see some of this mapping out again not
just in the United States the recent
European Parliament elections Greens
nationalists and the little Center was
just withering and and getting small do
you think we're going to get out of this
fever when you when you look and see a
Democratic Party that is much more
interested in democratic socialism and
expanding the Supreme Court's I think
half the field wants to do now these
days just a series of ideas that seem a
lot more untethered towards norms here
after the norm shattering president on
these sort of a populist right is this
just a bracketed era that we need to
survive what do you see that in the near
future as far as that well as the near
future right now we're seeing in the
Democratic field of candidates and
attempt to define a left-wing trumpery
that is to be just as silly as possible
all these things that they know are not
going to happen
I'm not going to abolish the Electoral
College I'm not going to take away
private health since you're just not
going to do it but because of the
dynamics of their nominating process
they feel they have to do this now they
can in the process repeat their amazing
achievement of 2016 which was electing
Donald Trump he could not have done it
without the Democratic Party and they
have figured out how to do it again
whether or not they're going to plunge
off that cliff lemming like I don't know
you quit if I'm not mistaken the
Republican Party in 2016 or in 2015 2016
June 3rd the day after Paul Ryan
endorsed Trump I said that's it the only
Republican has actually read the
constitution of Liberty
because endorse Trump that's it I'm out
of here and you've written favorably
about bill weld who's competing against
y'all Trump in this primary election so
are you backing him do you envision
coming back to the Republican Party is
it all Libertarian Party for you from
now on I find being a free agent
exhilarating
people say oh gee that must have been
wrenching leaving the Republican mind
dad daddy would tied up with a
Republican Party it's a utilitarian
device and when it quits being useful I
quit it's it's not it's not a wrenching
psychological spiritual moment politics
isn't about spiritual things so no I
don't find to go back to the Republican
Party you know I like it out here in the
cold very good well George well thank
you so much conservative Sensibility
it's the most impactful libertarian book
of the year he would despite not having
it in the India in the title thank you
very much for joining with you